Hello, and welcome to Emma Barnett Meets
and this week I'm meeting the space expert
and physicist, Professor Brian Cox
and I'm really looking
forward to asking him
about how he gets his head
around the vastness of space
and to explain it to all
of us or try to, anyway.
How he also goes about his daily life
when he knows how
insignificant we really are
and what he makes of NASA's new telescope
and those amazing images.
Welcome to the program.
Thank you so much for coming to talk to me
and to all of our viewers.
And I actually wanted to start
with the new NASA telescope.
We'll come to your particular
project in a moment,
but it's named after the man
who ran the agency in the '60s
and oversaw the first man
mission to the moon, James Webb.
What do you make of what
we're seeing so far?
'Cause it's pretty incredible.
Yeah, it's a remarkable instrument.
I mean, you think of the predecessor
which is Hubble Space telescope,
I think it's almost impossible
to imagine a world without that
even if you don't know the images
that we're familiar with of the universe,
many of them, the spectacular galaxies
and star-forming regions,
they're from Hubble.
But the Webb is a
significant step forward.
And technically, one of
the most important things
is it can see what we call
longer wavelength light
or infrared light.
And that's important
because if you think about,
we wanna see the first galaxies forming.
So we want to understand
how the first stars
and galaxies formed in the universe.
And so what you do is you
look far out into the universe
and because light travels quite slowly
across cosmic distances,
let's say you have a galaxy
that's the most distant one
you can see with the naked eye
is about 2 million light years away.
So that means that the
light has been traveling
for 2 million years to reach us.
And it's a remarkable thing
actually to think when you look,
it's called the Andromeda galaxy
and if you know where you're looking,
you can just catch it out
of the corner of your eye.
If you think about it,
you're seeing that as it was
2 million years ago.
Yes, although I don't-
Because it takes
the light 2 million years to travel.
I don't like being late to information,
so that makes me feel very out of date.
It's remarkable.
I mean, it began its journey
before we had evolved on earth.
So in the time it took,
and that's the nearest neighboring galaxy.
The Webb looks so far out
that it's capturing light
that's been traveling for
over 13 billion years.
But the universe has been expanding,
and so the light has been stretching.
And so for the most distant galaxies,
we're looking back in time
almost to the Big Bang.
The Hubble was not
sensitive to that light,
so that the Webb can see the formation
of the first galaxies.
It's essentially looking all the way back
to very close to the beginning of time.
And that's very important
because we're not entirely sure
exactly how those first galaxies formed.
The idea of what you just talked about
in terms of how much time this has taken
and what it's covering,
do you think we will ever
be able to see the Big Bang?
Well, we almost can.
It's not the Webb telescope,
there's something called
the cosmic microwave background radiation,
which is light that was
emitted in the universe
and it's a very precise number.
It's 380,000 years after the Big Bang
which is not very long at all, right.
The universe is 13.8 billion years old.
So we can see that,
it's microwaves because
it's been stretched so much
by the expansion of the universe.
Going back, the problem with light is that
in those earliest times,
the universe was so hot and so dense
that light couldn't travel through it.
So it was opaque.
So you can't use light to
go back earlier than that.
But what we can potentially do, not yet,
we're not good enough yet,
but the technology we use now
to detect colliding black holes,
which is another remarkable thing,
but I'll leave that one aside for now,
but we have the technology to do that.
And that technology possibly
could allow us to probe
right back to this thing,
the Big Bang
and again, whether or not
that's the origin of time
we can talk about as well.
Brian, you've dedicated your life
to explaining the scale
of the universe to people.
You have a new world tour
and show called Horizons.
What was the goal?
Are you trying to teach people new things
and understand the world
they're living in better?
Or what are you aiming for?
Well, actually all those things.
So it works, I hope, on different levels.
So I talk about cosmology,
we've spoken about
what we call the large scale
structure of the universe.
So the galaxies and how they formed,
how the universe has
evolved since the Big Bang.
But also I've got very interested
in my academic work in black holes.
And black holes, and they're
really evocative things.
I think everyone's heard
of these strange things,
these totally collapsed stars,
from which nothing apparently can escape.
But in the past few years,
past few decades, really,
beginning work that Stephen
Hawking really began
back in the 1970s and many others,
we've begun to suspect
there's a lot more to them.
And they've started forcing us
to reassess our understanding
of what space and time are.
And that's a really weird sentence.
You might think, well, space
is the arena in which we live
and time just ticks, but it really isn't.
It looks like, from studying these things,
there are building blocks of space
and building blocks of time.
And what I say in the show is
that's a mind blowing idea,
and I talk about that.
But the key point is there's
a great quote from Einstein,
a beautiful story that Einstein told
about when he was a little boy,
he was six or seven years old
and his dad gave him a compass.
And so he looks at the compass
and he saw, well, there's
this thing, this needle
and it always points north,
points in this direction.
So there's something
invisible that I can't see
that underlies our reality,
that's making this needle point north.
And he said later in life,
it was my first encounter with an idea,
which is if you look at nature carefully
and really pay attention and you're lucky,
you can catch a glimpse of
something deeply hidden,
which is a beautiful phrase.
Something deeply hidden,
which is the deep structure of reality.
It's what our reality is.
And so black holes, they're
kind of a metaphor in a way.
I talk about them as
Rosetta stones in the sky.
They're the things that by studying them,
and you say, "Why, why would
we study these things?"
Well in studying these things,
we're beginning to get a deep picture
of what our reality actually is.
And that's a remarkable idea
but it's a beautiful idea that
runs through all of science.
How do you define a black hole?
Well, it's in Einstein's theory,
which is again it's a remarkable thing,
it's probably in 1915,
over a hundred years old.
But it's just a region of space
from which even light can't escape.
And by understanding what they are,
and knowing more about
them, what do we then learn?
Well, so Stephen Hawking back in the '70s
published a paper,
the initial one was called
"Black Hole Explosions",
which is a great title for a paper.
And he calculated, he
found out that black holes,
in his language, he said
black holes ain't so black.
They glow in the sky like coals in the sky
and they radiate.
And so over time, they lose energy
and mass and ultimately
disappear over huge time scales.
And that's so important and I
show this picture in the show
that if you go into Westminster Abbey
and look on the floor
of Westminster Abbey,
on Stephen's memorial stone,
then you'd find his equation
for the temperature of a black hole
literally chiseled in stone
on the floor of an abbey.
So you might say, "Why?
Why is it so important?"
This was the key, this was
his Rosetta stone idea.
In trying to understand what happens,
what happens to the stuff that fell in?
When you thought these
things existed forever,
which is pre-Hawking, right,
then you think, well, it's okay.
It gets locked up inside,
it can never get out.
We don't care.
But the thing evaporates
away, one day it will be gone.
So then suddenly you have to
be faced with this question,
what happened to everything then?
If I threw a book into a black hole,
is it somehow possible in the far future
if you collect all this
so-called Hawking radiation
that comes off, is it
possible to reconstruct
the information in the book?
And that's been a
question, simple question,
that's driven this
tremendous amount of research
for 50 years
and it was pretty much sold
in 2019, actually, in 2020,
pretty much.
I mean, there's still a
huge number of questions.
But roughly, well, the statement is
everything comes out again,
all the information comes out.
So everything that fell in, in principle,
in the far future you could
reconstruct the information
of everything that fell in.
It just an astonishing idea
because actually, the last
thing I'll say is that
before that, before the Hawking papers
and before this modern understanding,
inside a black hole, just
according to Einstein,
sits the end of time
which is an astonishing thing to say,
'cause we can see them.
We have a photograph
of one of these things
in the center of galaxy too, actually.
And when you look at that photograph,
you're looking at the
end of time in space.
So then you think, well, if
things go to the end of time,
how does everything get out again?
And that's the content
of this tremendous work
in theoretical physics.
This work, studying black holes,
it's one of those things
that a certain kind of person
says is useless, right.
He said, "Why?
Who cares?"
It turns out that the techniques
that are being developed
and the understanding that's being gained
from looking at these things
has got a very strong crossover
with building quantum computers.
Quantum computers are in laboratories now,
they have a tremendous potential
to revolutionize our civilization.
Incredibly powerful computing devices.
Well yes, and also that
sometimes the defense given,
isn't it, about what's going into
man going back to the moon or
woman going back to the moon.
The other things are
discovered in the pursuit
of those missions.
Yeah, I mean, it's always
a cliche, but it's true.
A friend of mine, an
astronomer, always says,
"When people criticize these spacecraft
and they say you know, the Webb,
let's say the James Webb
space telescope was what,
6 billion or so."
But it's appropriate to point out
that nobody put 6 billion in a suitcase
and launched it on the rockets.
The 6 billion didn't go into space.
It was spent on earth.
And what is often the case,
so putting aside the glory and wonder
of the discoveries that are made,
that basically, you are paying
people to do high tech jobs
and do research and build
machines that operate
at the edge of the possible
and history tells us that that
tends to be extremely useful.
You're inventing things
and trying to do things
that are difficult
and that expertise never
stays in one place.
It then spreads out
across our civilization
in ways that you can't really
predict or even quantify.
Indeed and you did sound
very excited earlier.
I mean, you sound excited the whole time
about all of this, which is infectious
even if we're, people trying
to keep up, including myself.
But when you talked about
the golden possibility
of there being life out there,
and that question of are we alone?
Where are you with that?
What do you say to people right now
with the latest information?
Well, so again, I think
there's in cosmology,
I say this in the show as well,
it's one of the most challenging subjects
because at one level, it
makes us feel very, very small
and insignificant and
it's true, physically.
I mean the earth is one planet
around one star amongst 400
billion stars in one galaxy
amongst 2 trillion galaxies
in the part of the universe we can see.
So we're definitely small, right?
So you can't argue that.
Yes, you've clarified that.
But, you're right.
If you ask the question about life,
the answer is we don't know.
We found nothing, nothing
alive beyond the earth.
But admittedly, we haven't been very far
or looked tremendously hard.
Although we are looking hard now on Mars
because we suspect there might
have been microbes on Mars
because there was once water on Mars
and it was geologically active
and all the things that we think
led to the origin of life on
earth were present on Mars
around the same time,
about three and a half
to 4 billion years ago.
So we wouldn't be surprised
if we find that microbes existed,
probably, subsurface on Mars
or maybe on some of the
moons of Jupiter or Saturn
where there's water today.
However,
nobody expects anything more
complicated than a microbe.
And it's interesting.
So, if you look at the
history of life on earth,
you have microbes around
3.8 billion years ago,
pretty much, not long
after the earth formed
in geological time.
But if you look for evidence
of complex life on earth,
then really there isn't
any in the fossil record
until about 600 million years ago or so.
So on this planet, for most
of the history of the planet,
there was slime, basically.
Single-celled things
doing interesting stuff,
photosynthesis and things,
but nothing more complicated
than a single cell.
And it's only in the last
half a billion years or so
that you get this
explosion of life on earth.
And only as I said, it's only in the last
less than a million years
that we've had Homo sapiens on earth.
And in the last few tens
of thousands of years,
we've had a civilization.
So here, it took pretty
much 4 billion years
to go from cell to civilization.
And that's a third of
the age of the universe.
And so that leads many
biologists that I speak to
to suggest that whilst
microbes might be common,
civilizations might be rare.
Actually I asked a friend of mine,
a great physicist, Sean Carroll,
how many civilizations do you think
there will be in a Milky Way
galaxy, a typical galaxy?
How many in a typical galaxy?
And he said, "None."
Right, none.
And I tend to say one.
So somewhere between
zero and one, probably.
But, that's a guess.
But do you want there to be?
I think it's a good guess.
Brian, is that what it is?
You sound like perhaps you
have an optimism for it,
and I wonder what's underpinning that?
I would love there to be.
And actually, because it worries me
and this is the way that
I end my show, actually.
It worries me that let's
take that position.
Let's imagine that in our
galaxy, 400 billion suns,
there's just us that thinks, right.
I mean microbes all over the place,
but in terms of things
that think and can feel,
and in a very real sense,
bring meaning to the universe,
all these things we've talked about,
the beauty of these galaxies.
They're not beautiful
if there's nothing there
to perceive them, right?
They're just galaxies.
So if that's it in this galaxy,
then the decisions that we make now,
as a civilization, have
a, galactic implications.
If we destroy ourselves, for example,
deliberately or through inaction,
then it's possible that we
eliminate meaning perhaps forever
in a galaxy of 400 billion stars.
So I think that leads you to,
it's a good working assumption,
that we have a tremendous
responsibility, in a sense,
not to do that.
So I would be much more comfortable
with our current predicament
if the galaxy was filled
with civilizations.
Then I'd say, "Well, okay.
It would be rather stupid of us
to eliminate all this
beautiful culture and science
and arts and music that we built up.
But at least there's someone
else that's doing that."
But I'm not actually sure there is.
How comfortable are you with space tourism
and the pursuit of that
knowledge and meaning
being left largely to a very
small group of rich men?
You're right.
The idea that the technology is used,
if all it was used for was to send a few
very, very rich people
into space on a joy ride,
then there will be a real criticism there.
But that's not all the
technology is used for.
So I think it's important
to understand that
the space industry is
about operating initially,
near earth orbits and we've
already industrialized that.
We all use it everyday.
I mean, we all switch on
our sat navs in the car,
satellite navigation, it
requires infrastructure in orbit.
A lot of the stuff we
know about climate change,
resource use and so on,
that's coming from satellites.
So I think you have to look at
the space industry as a whole
really and say, well, it's not just about,
the same argument was made
for intercontinental travel by aircraft,
it's true, when the first
aircraft were built.
It was extremely expensive
in the preserve of the rich.
But of course, within a few decades
it had democratized travel
and we all take advantage
of that every day.
So I think that's the
right way to look at space.
It's not to focus on particular bits of it
that we might not like for
moral reasons or whatever it is.
So it's actually, I really do advocate
for the fact of looking
at the whole industry,
which is tremendously important now.
It is, I mean I am interested
though that you did say,
and correct me if I'm wrong,
that all political leaders
should go to space,
perhaps for some perspective.
Do you still think that?
Yeah, and I did say oh,
most of them should come back.
Most of them.
Very good, very good,
that's the last part of that quote.
Yeah.
Yeah, it was based on an idea,
which is a very famous idea
called the overview effect,
which is well known that
astronauts change their view
of the always, as far as I'm aware anyway,
that when they come back,
they have a more positive view
of the value of this planet
and are very much more
focused on preserving it
as a beautiful place,
perhaps a unique place in
a galaxy, as I've said.
So I felt that,
and I do feel that having the good fortune
speaking to many astronauts,
that their experience,
if the people who make the decisions,
the big decisions about our future,
could have that experience,
I think would be good investments.
It's extremely hard argument to make
that we should actually spend
money allowing, you know,
in our case, at the moment,
our Prime Minister, right.
So in the UK, we'd say,
"Well, we should spend
money sending Boris Johnson
into space and bringing him
back safely to earth again
because it would change his view."
Now I don't think I'd win that argument.
No, but-
But,
I think there's a serious point there,
which is that it does seem to
change people for the better
when they see our earth as it really is,
which is a fragile thing
against the blackness of space.
So I think it is an argument
that I would try to make.
I would lose it
because it's very expensive.
Do you want to go, are you willing to go?
I would love to, because as I said,
I'd love to share that experience
of seeing our world from space.
I think it's really, unarguably,
it appears to be a life
changing experience
and it seems to change
individuals for the better.
You won't be scared?
Well, I don't know.
I mean, I remember one of
my great heroes, John Young,
who flew on the Apollo
missions, walked on the moon,
test flew the first space shuttle
and he said that anyone who sits on top of
however many thousands of tons
of liquid hydrogen and oxygen
and isn't a bit worried,
doesn't understand the problem.
So he's probably right.
Do you have people come and
talk to you about faith?
Do they talk to you about how religion
and that side of life fits
into your level of knowledge?
Because I know you've
traveled around the world
talking to people.
Yeah, a lot.
It comes up as a question
because cosmology it's
a science of origins.
And actually, with the
study of black holes,
as I've mentioned,
we're even beginning now
to think about what space and time are.
So naturally the, I say
it in the show, actually,
I say, when we're talking about this,
it's the moment of creation if there was.
So we're asking, was there
a moment of creation?
And that's the correct
language to use, I think.
It's evocative language,
but it's really what we're talking about.
Did everything come into being,
or has it always been here?
We actually don't even know
the answer to that question, really.
So yeah, I get asked it a lot
because I think cosmology
is a challenging science
that challenges us to
think about these things
that we often, you know,
we associate that with
theology or philosophy.
And I think that's a good thing
because something I
very strongly believe in
is that segmenting or
making little canisters
and putting different
bits of human experience
or different music and art and theology
and philosophy and science
and segmenting them all
is just the wrong way to look at it.
What we are doing is a deep
level trying to understand
what it means to be
human in this tremendous,
potentially, infinite universe.
And so those questions get asked.
And ultimately I say, I'm
quite straightforward,
I say, "I'm not a
religious person myself."
But the correct thing to say,
even about the question did the universe
have a beginning in
time, is we don't know.
We don't know and that's it
Professor Brian Cox, thank you so much
for your time and your insight.
Thank you very much.
And thank you to you for being with us.
Until next time, goodbye.